And the answer is no, there is no
solution that the agent can come up with
because Bucharest doesn't
appear on the map and so
the agent doesn't know any
actions that can arrive there.
So let's give the agent a better chance.
Now we've given the agent
the full map of Romania.
The start is in Arad and
the destination, or
goal, is in Bucharest and
the agent is given the problem
of coming up with a sequence of actions
that will arrive at the destination.
Now is it possible for
the agent to solve this problem?
And the answer is yes.
There are many routes or steps or
sequences of actions that will
arrive at the destination.
Here's one of them.
Starting out in Arad taking
this step first, then this one.
And then this one, then this one,
and then this one,
to arrive at the destination.
So that would count as
a solution to the problem.
So, sequence of actions,
chained together, that are guaranteed
to get us to the goal.
Now, let's formally define
what a problem looks like.
A problem can be broken down
into a number of components.
First, the initial state that
the agent starts out with.
In our route finding problem,
the initial state was the agent
being in the city of Arad.
Next a function actions that
takes a status input and
returns a set of
possible actions that the agent can
execute when the agent is in the state.
In some problems,
the agent will have the same
actions available in all states.
And in other problems they'll have
different actions dependent on
the state.
In the route finding problem,
the actions are dependent on the state.
When we're in one city we can take the
routes to the neighboring cities, but
we can't go to any other cities.
Next, we have.
A function called result
which takes as input a state.
And an action and
delivers as its output, a new state.
So for example,
if the agent is in the city of Arad,
and, that would be the state, and
takes the action of driving along
route E671 towards Timisoara, then the
result of applying that action in that
state would be the new state where
the agent is in the city of Timisoara.
Next, we need a function.
Called GoalTest which takes a state.
And returns a boolean value true or
false,
telling us if this data is a goal or
not.
In a route finding problem,
the only goal would be being in the
destination city, the city of Bucharest,
and all the other states would
return false for the goal test.
And finally, one more thing,
which is a path
cost function which takes a path,
a sequence of state action transitions
and returns a number which
is the cost of that path.
Now for most of the problems we'll deal
with we'll make the path cost function
be additive so that the cost of the path
is just the sum of the individual steps.
And so
we'll implement this path cost function
in terms of a step cost function.
The step cost function takes a state,
an action, and
the resulting state from that action.
And returns a number n which
is the cost of that action.
In the route finding example, the cost
might be the number of miles traveled,
or maybe the number of minutes it
takes to get to that destination.